welcome back it's now the final day of
our journey and at long last the great
moment arrives
I'm granted an official meeting with the
woman herself the president of Finland
my international twin Turia Hallinan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
marinated see thank you very much thank
you for inviting me your lioness is very
hiding what impression fooled me too
in the other room okay I asked you to
wait here for a short woman no problem
and we have our guest pool over there if
you like to sign and this is addressing
the country or my addressing Madam
President whatever you want
she just assumed thank you very much
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my torso is this big my legs are 3/4 of
my body I think they're about the same
same amount of they must like you having
different form but similarity here you
don't I don't think I think they need to
feet so they can some baby might don't
see right here I'll see no I think a
little bit a little bit I think it's
just that it looks much better on you
than on me yeah like so what I would I
would like to ask is that coming to your
parents so am I looking like your father
or your mother
oh okay you're looking much more like my
mom oh yeah yeah no very good it's a
good thing yeah oh not to my father
yeah this is my mother yeah I'm glad
that your country and my little TV show
have come together nice thing you have
made also there Kate favor for for us
because I think that at least now quite
many more America's no way our families
we have half officer joking that that
really I would like to thank you very
coordinate I've always thought if our
show can't be that amusing at least we
can teach people geography
[Music]
[Applause]